the most embarrassing thing I ever did
in high school I work khaki pants with
New Balance running shoes look rather
than tell you how bad things are in
Virginia for Democrats at the moment let
me show you how bad things are yes in
the span of five days three of the top
Democratic party officials in Virginia
saw the all but book of their political
careers and obviously that might be
underselling it the reson Vinick
collapse like it in modern political
memory and maybe not ever okay so let's
start from the start on February first a
conservative website called big-league
politics posted a picture from
Democratic Governor Ralph Northam 'he's
1984 medical school yearbook page
sidebar why do medical schools have
yearbooks the pictures showed two men
one in blackface the other in the
distinctive white robes of the Ku Klux
Klan shortly after the picture surface
Northam released this apologetic
statement that photo and the racist and
offensive attitudes that represents does
not reflect that person I am today or
the way that I have conducted myself as
a soldier a doctor and a public servant
I'm deeply sorry oh that seems pretty
open-and-shut right
white governor of a state in which one
in five residents are black a Pierson
black face in his mid-20s and admits yes
I appeared in blackface in my mid-20s
that's time to resign buddy except it
wasn't less than 24 hours after saying
in that statement that he regretted
being in that picture Northam held a
press conference but it wasn't to resign
it was to say he was wait for it
mistaken turns out it wasn't him in the
picture at all even though he admitted
it was him but in that same press
conference Northam did acknowledge that
he went in blackface to a dance party in
the mid-1980s in hopes of more closely
resembling Michael Jackson a reporter
asked Northam whether he could still
moonwalk
my wife says in appropriate
circumstances yeah for at least a second
and a half a white governor under fire
for appearing in blackface was going to
try to moonwalk this happened it
happened on planet Earth
it happened in 2019 oh that's true now
if the story stop there
that's about it still be a hell of a
story but it didn't stop there
not even close even as the political
world was trying to process the whole
moonwalk press conference big league
politics was at it again publishing
allegation from a woman who said that
Justin Fairfax Virginia stem aquatic
lieutenant governor and a rising
african-american star of the state party
had sexually assaulted her during the
2004 Democratic National Convention in
Boston a Fairfax angrily denied the
allegation and made a not-so-subtle
suggestion that people aligned with his
political rivals were trying to bring
him down
does anybody think it's any coincidence
that when they Eve potentially my being
elevated the bats win this
uncorroborated smear comes out does
anybody believe that's a coincidence
now while we were all pondering the
answer to that question Virginia
Attorney General Mark herring dropped
another bombshell writing this on
Twitter quote in 1980 when I was a 19
year old undergraduate in college some
friends suggested we attend a party
dressed like rappers we listened to at
the time like Kurtis Blow and perform a
song it sounds ridiculous even now
writing it but because we're ignorant in
club attitudes and because we did not
have an appreciation for the experiences
and perspectives of others we dressed up
and put on wigs and brown makeup and
quote now brown makeup is herring
admitting he too went to a party in
blackface so in the space of five days
we had three separate scandals involving
the three top elected officials all
Democrats in Virginia with two white
politicians wearing blackface and a
black politician facing down a sexual
assault charge
but the story still wasn't done one week
after the Northland photo broke a second
woman came forward alleging that fairfax
raped her when they were both
undergraduates at Duke Fairfax again
denied the allegations insisting that he
had engaged in consensual sexual
relations with both women he called for
a further investigation into the
accusations Northam who after going
silent to survive a cavalcade of calls
for his resignation over that past week
inexplicably decided to give an
interview to CBS News in which he
referred to slavery as indentured
servitude in 1619 the first indentured
servants from Africa landed on our
shores and Old Point Comfort what we
call now Fort Monroe and Wow
also known as slavery yes and said that
the big lesson he had learned from all
of this is that blackface is offensive
to some african-americans you do not
know that you were born into white
privilege I knew I was mr. King but I
didn't realize really
the powerful implications of that I've
also learned why the use of blackface is
so offensive and yes I knew it in the
past but reality has really set in thick
seriously it is literally like you're
trying to get yourself kicked out of
office now where does the story go from
here at the moment none of the tree of
Virginia Democrats is resigning and
weirdly there's some strength in those
numbers if one of the three decided to
call it quits amid scandal it would make
it a lot harder for the other two to
hang on now regardless of whether
Northam fairfax and herring survived
this moment however all three have
suffered considerable damage to their
political futures such as they might
have them but the more important
takeaway here is this Virginia over the
past decade has been one of the
Democratic Party's great success stories
it went from a reliably Republican state
to one in which Democrats held the lion
share of key political offices this
entire disaster tarnishes that rise and
threatens to hand republicans an
opportunity in their state elections
this fall and well beyond
and that is the point we make new point
episodes every Tuesday and Thursday you
got to catch them all